NARRATOR: OK, there's this Argentinian guy
named Adolfo Cambiaso.
Many call him "The
G.O.A.T of polo."
You know, the sport with
the horses and the sticks
and the ball and all
the money, like the logo
on your collared shirt.
Adolfo has been ranked among
the world's best polo players
for 22 years straight.
So random question.
What is this G.O.A.T of polo
have to do with a businessman
named Alan and his pancreas?
That actually leads
to a pretty crazy
story about how clones
are transforming
sports and your life.
Well, maybe not yet, but soon.
So let's take a deeper look
at how the polo G.O.A.T
and the pancreas are linked.
Let's start from the beginning.
Meet Alan Meeker.
He's a businessman-- Texas
through and through--
and he loves horses.
But like 30 million
Americans, he's got diabetes.
Clearly, being a
financier and all,
Meeker had a few
extra and unusual
resources at his disposal.
And he started researching
whether cloning his pancreas
could cure his diabetes, and
it could have change lives.
But alas, the cloned
pancreas was a no-go.
But Meeker learned
a lot, and he became
an amateur cloning
expert fascinated
by what it could do for polo.
So he set up a cloning
company in Texas.
Meeker licensed the technology
that had been cloning
all kinds of mammals
since 1996 including
a famous sheep named Dolly.
So Meeker figured it
wouldn't be much of a stretch
to clone horses, too.
But he wanted to work
with the best DNA.
So he flew all the way to
Argentina-- the mecca of polo.
When he got there, Meeker
met with that Argentinean guy
we talked about earlier.
You know, The G.O.A.T, Adolfo?
Adolfo's prized
horse died almost
10 years earlier after an
injury in a championship match.
Ever the
forward-thinking G.O.A.T,
Adolfo saved his horse's DNA,
and Meeker had to have it.
Together, the two set out to
clone and breed a horse army.
Just kidding.
Scratch that.
Together, the two set out to
clone and breed the best herd
of polo horses on Planet
Earth and revolutionize
the game of polo--
#squadgoals.
And clone they did.
Meeker and The
G.O.A.T have created
more than 25 clones of
Cambiaso's champion polo
horses.
And their company, Crestview,
has cloned more than 200 horses
since 2009.
Some are even breeding.
And miraculously, in 2017, a
polo championship was won using
the DNA of those prized horses.
You heard that right.
The G.O.A.T won the Argentine
Open riding only cloned horses.
So thanks to Alan Meeker's
pancreatic problems
and visionary
thinking, you can now
own a cloned horse of
your own for upwards
of a cool $100,000 US dollars.
But that's not the whole story.
For more, watch new
episodes of Explorer
on National Geographic.
[music playing]